search and rescue teams are continuing
their efforts to find survivors of flash
floods that swamped eastern kentucky at
least 19 people including six children
were killed when torrential rains dumped
as much as 10 and a half inches in just
two days kentucky's governor warning
that the number of dead could rise
sharply as emergency crews struggle to
reach rural areas that are among the
poorest in the country meteorologist
mike seidel from our partners at the
weather channel is in hindman kentucky
where many people are still missing mike
good morning
good morning dana i'm in front of the
troublesome creek so aptly named because
overnight wednesday night and into
thursday morning
six inches of rain fell in three hours
it came rushing down all these mountain
sides and hillsides in eastern kentucky
and the creek went from where it is now
up to the top of the bridge the force of
the water brought this suv flipped it
over downstream many of the residents
had little time to react and this
morning the search and rescue continues
for the unaccounted for
as the flood waters in parts of
southeastern kentucky began to recede
the extent of the damage became clearer
right now it's looking like we're not
going to be able to save it entire towns
have been flooded roads destroyed and
major infrastructure power water and
cell phone service wiped out there's
nothing really that you can do but you
know we're just glad we got out
crews have already rescued nearly 300
people and many more are still
unaccounted for
governor andy beshear toured the region
by helicopter and later warned the death
toll will go up from everything we've
seen
we may be updating
the count of how many we lost for the
next several weeks
flood waters triggered by torrential
rains surged through the small town of
pineman inundating the elementary school
and leaving it under a thick crust of
mud classes were to begin in less than
two weeks but not anymore the school is
kind of the heart where everybody comes
together and so that's
it's hard kentucky is just one of
several states left reeling from severe
flooding monsoonal rains washed through
parts of nevada soaking unlucky gamblers
on the las vegas strip scientists say
climate change amplifies these storms
and the damage they leave behind in
kentucky recovery will be slow
we're going to grieve with you
we're going to support you and we're
going to be here for you not just today
but tomorrow and in the weeks and the in
the years to come
right now there's still nearly 20 000
customers in kentucky without power
combine that with a flash flooding and
some water systems are still not up and
running so the governor has rushed
plenty of drinking water to those
affected areas the best news of all in
several days is
all right mike seidel there in kentucky
thank you very much